and it is an immense honor and pleasure
to stand here today
in this position it's not a position
that i expected to be in
some weeks ago uh however things
can change quite radically first of all
want to say thanks to almighty god for
giving me the health and strength to do
this
because i have my own challenges earlier
this year i won't pay particular tribute
to my wife
and to my family for the support that
they have been not just
over the course of the last number of
weeks but over the course of my
over 20 years in politics and i also
want to pay particular tribute and to my
election team
who have worked fantastically well and
have been on call
um virtually 24 hours a day worked
around the clock
to help secure this victory i'm looking
forward to
a positive relationship right across
northern ireland
and with my party colleagues out indeed
with people from other parties i think
that the opportunities for northern
ireland are great
the opportunities for us to make
northern ireland a great place
after this hundred years has passed and
we move into a new hundred years
our immense we have had great people in
northern ireland over those years
but the greatest thing in northern
ireland is the resilience of all of its
people
and from its outset it's had its trials
in the 1920s there were civil war
in the 1930s we had a depression in the
1940s there was a war
in 1950s there was another insurrection
by the ira
that started again in the late 60s and
worked its way right through
to 1994 and
throughout all of that our people have
shown
remarkable resilience and there's that
resilience that we
are going to go forward and make
northern ireland a great place
my father was a founder member of the
dep
some 50 years ago and i joined it after
the
death of the reverend robin robert
bradford mp
and at 1981 and throughout all of that
period
this party has been the authentic voice
of unionism and will continue to be the
authentic voice
of unionism under my leadership
the opportunities are great we want to
ensure that
for young people there is good jobs
available
in northern ireland educationally
we tackle the issues where um young
people from more deprived backgrounds
get greater opportunity want to increase
your university places
there is so much to do we have work to
do in our health service
which is greatly challenged at this time
with waiting lists which are horrendous
anywhere in the united kingdom so
there's much to do
there's much to be done and i stand here
today
very proud to be taking up the mantle as
leader of the democratic
unionist party and that brings with it a
responsibility to all of unionism
i want to say this very clearly i will
be
a leader in unionism who will be
reaching out to
other leaders in unionism i want
to see unionism working together
the northern ireland protocol has proven
to be a
massive challenge for us and if we are
to
fight this to ensure that everybody in
northern ireland
is not worse off as a consequence of the
protocol
then it's for us to do that together and
i want
to ensure that that is the case that we
don't have the unionist bickering
that we've had in the past and i will
encourage all unionists to work with me
to deliver an end which ensures we set
the foundations in this 2021
for another 100 years of northern
ireland within the united kingdom
thank you
the new leader of the democratic
unionist party
in northern ireland it couldn't be
closer could it david blevins was
telling us
it was on a knife edge this vote and
uh edwin puts the agriculture minister
got 19 votes so jeffrey donaldson the
other
contender got 17
there so 36 members of the party's
electoral college
voting uh you can see there david
blevins for us our senior
ireland correspondent so this was close
but we know
now who has edged it
yes they came remarkably close to a tie
which would have required the party
to conduct the entire leadership contest
all over again
but i think we can say two things as a
result of what we've just heard in the
last few minutes
one the dup is an almost equally divided
party between the pragmatic wing
it's representative in this contest
being sir jeffrey donaldson
and the ideological wing its
representative the victorious candidate
edwin pouch northern ireland's
agriculture minister he has a great job
of work ahead of him if he's going to
try to
reunite northern ireland's largest party
the democratic unionists
without further dividing the power
sharing government here at stormont
which is already wobbling
as a result of difficulties around the
northern ireland protocol
that brexit border in the irish sea i
think
the other thing that we have to make
very clear is that this marks
a seismic shift for the democratic
unionist party it is
an example of the grassroots of the
party taking back control if you like
from those who've been the top brass for
the last
decade one of the complaints that led to
the internal revolt against arlene
foster
was the fact that those who serve here
in the northern ireland assembly
felt there was a disconnect between them
to some degree
and those in the leadership of the party
and those who sit in
westminster for the party but many
people will be very very surprised that
sir jeffrey donaldson
a man who's been an mp for 24 years who
currently leads the party's westminster
team
and in his role as chief whip there
formerly was the man who negotiated that
one billion pound
confidence and supply deal with the
tories back in 2017
has not been victorious edwin putz
northern ireland's agriculture minister
a man who's held many different
portfolios here at stormont has just
edged it but he absolutely represents
that more ideological
more traditional more religious wing of
the dup and has in the past quartered
controversy
because of his strongly held views on
issues like evolution
and homosexuality